[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy find practical advice
that you can use in your everyday life
hi I'm Dan Haynes and I'm joined by my
co-host Dr Greg Sadler and today we're
talking about reacting rationally to red
flags and so this is something that
requires us to do some clarification I
think a lot of people are familiar with
the notion of a red flag something that
like you know sets you off and you say
oh I I better watch this person here but
there isn't an a universally like
consensus agreed upon definition of red
flags so I mean before we even start
looking at what other people have to say
I mean Dan do you have a handy
one liner about what a red flag is
a potential
extra negative things extra negative
okay that that's that's interesting yeah
because I think a lot of people use this
term a bit carelessly these days just
like they use other you know terms like
gaslighting like any time you know you
manipulate somebody or lie to them it's
gaslighting no no gaslighting is
something a little bit more specific and
maybe you know before we call something
a red flag we have to have I don't know
a certain threshold of right
problem yeah
usually it's it's in response to like
some of that you're in relationship to
although it doesn't have to be something
like romantic it can be like hey you uh
want to be working with this person you
want you know to be a close friend with
this person these are all things that
are something you're trying to kind of
suss out especially when you're new to
that person to kind of figure out what
they're they're like and what are their
values and yeah um some things are just
they're going to be quarks the
personalities no one's going to be
exactly like you
um but other things are
potential you know will result in really
negative outcomes for you or them or
both
you know I like that emphasis on novelty
if you are just noticing red flags with
somebody that you've been in a
relationship with like a personal
relationship or a business relationship
um 10 years in and their personality
hasn't radically changed like in that
that time I mean you could be like well
you just weren't paying attention that
entire time or now you know more but
odds are somebody's going to look at you
and say you're only noticing that red
flag now you know right it's uh you
should not expect
um what figs in Winter right that uh all
right yeah or
um or if it's a fig tree you should not
expect it to grow oranges that's you
know people
usually have a
you know especially as they get older
settle into certain patterns and Norms
oh yeah they can change but it's not
usually the norm yeah you know it's
interesting too that you mentioned that
because I suppose you could say that as
the culture changes there are some
things that were not red flags before
and then they they get seen as other by
other people as red flags all right
but we guess we could oh good no go
ahead
um you know I was thinking the the
different ways that people you know um
might like
generationally look in and what are the
values that they look for in like a
partner for example I might change all
the time and um as our
Society moved away from like that you
know that single man Breadwinner too a
you know a multi
um income household that has really
changed some of the uh the values and
the expectations on both socially and
economically for each of those uh
individuals and what would be considered
you know virtuous or excellent of
someone in one era who would be probably
really detrimental of the other
that for example
um if you're in a relationship and
you've got a two income household and
you're still expecting the wife to uh
take care of all of the uh household
chores yeah yeah
and extra labor right then then you're
you're probably going to have an unhappy
spouse
you know I was just laughing because I
was thinking about
um how over the course of you know my
lifetime attitudes about smoking in
public spaces have changed so much
because I was I was a smoker when I was
young I started smoking when I was 17
and then uh continued on really through
my 20s and
there were you know a lot of places
where you could smoke and then they
changed the laws and when they did it
all all the smokers were up in arms oh
this is tyranny this is awful you know
who are they to do that and then we
started to realize you know once we
stopped smoking and the haze cleared
away just the uh terrible uh burden that
we were putting on all the the
non-smokers and now I mean if I were a
smoker I wouldn't think of lighting up
at a bar or you know places like that as
a matter of fact we went to this is
totally off topic but it just kind of
illustrates that we went to some music
festivals uh over the last summer
and we almost had to leave because when
you're in these open-air festivals
suddenly like all the smokers are just
constantly smoking and it's it's so
thick if you're not used to it it's you
know your eyes start burning and your
sinuses get messed up and you know uh so
you know if somebody were to like walk
into my classroom and just light up
after class is over like we used to do
as college students and professors would
do too that would be a red flag right
but in 1990 that wouldn't have been a
red flag that would have been considered
normal behavior
and
and I was in college there were
quite a few International
s and you know from other cultures
especially like the the Chinese
Nationals
um their the smoking culture is is quite
large at least it was you know
um when I was in college and so like the
the regular American student body wasn't
smoking but you'd see large portions of
these Chinese Nationals that that word
is just their cultural norm and it's
totally outside of what we would expect
yeah so let's come back to like well
what are red flags I mean there are like
I said there's no consensus definition
but we can say that a lot of things
about it that kind of flesh out the
concept
um so you know we could say that there's
something that appears within the scope
of a possible or actual maybe starting
or continuing relationship and there's a
lot of venues in which this can can
happen you talked about romantic
relationships I think a lot of people
associate red flags with that but we can
also talk about the workplace or
um business partners you know that we
look at and we're like I'm not sure
about this proposal academic
institutions I actually asked my
students today about uh red flags and I
asked them about professors you know
like how do they tell who is going to be
a problematic Professor they came up
with you know some of the things that
they'd observed uh for you know
professors who are the ones to avoid
unless you can't get out of their
classes
um but you know there's uh other things
that we we found so there's a great
Psychology today post by Abigail Brenner
and I like this phrase and I'd be
curious to see what you think about this
intuitive indicators that something
needs to be questioned is that I mean
that's the intuitive thing that's like
our gut sense
is that enough that it needs to be
questioned or
do we need to go further for it to be a
red flag what do you think
well my intuitive feeling that it is
that it might need a little bit more
than that okay oh
although is you got to start someplace
you have to have some intuitive thing
to I don't know like it it feels like I
want something more there okay but I
think it's a working definition yeah you
need more meat you could say so how
about this one so this is from a couples
counselor
um uh folache
it may be mispronouncing the name red
flags are behaviors that give you
serious pause or should give you serious
pause and that could sometimes indicate
a larger
pattern I think I think that's got more
of the meat that I'm looking for okay
but it's not quite there yet right
I mean a larger pattern a larger pattern
of what I want to know you know yeah
um something potentially detrimental I
think they have to have something
otherwise it's you know it's a larger
pattern of
what
yeah I mean some people actually talk
about green flags right so you could
have a larger good pattern and you see
that you're like oh that's the kind of
person I want but we want yeah we want
something problematic we want something
dangerous something
harmful something
bad for us in in other modalities maybe
um I mean I've seen other people talk
about it as a danger sign uh something
and I've seen the word deal breaker used
to and when we talk about something
being a deal breaker we mean uh you know
we won't put up with that kind of
behavior
now
I don't know I mean a lot of people do
see red flags and then ignore them so I
don't know that that definitional works
completely
I guess
I think it's got to be a little bit
wider than that we can't just call it
only danger signs because there's going
to be red flags okay that are
not dangerous but it just means that
we're not going to be a a match for that
person so like maybe you would be
unhappy staying with them but there
isn't anything really bad that's going
to happen it's just a a lack of goods or
blockage of what ought to develop or
something like that
right I think that's uh
along the path that I'm looking for okay
well let's let's move on a little bit so
I mean we do want to note that
there are lots of lists of red flags out
there but it's not as if any one of
these lists
um is perfect well there's no it's not
just not that it's comprehensive there's
also kind of a relativity to this like
some things that a person who has been
traumatized pretty badly you know burned
in the past as we say
um something might count as a red flag
for them that doesn't for the rest of us
uh absolutely there's uh there's totally
this like whole range you know not only
you know for the individual there's
going to be these personal red flags
like what they're looking for in a a
partner or you know a roommate or you
know in a business situation all these
things where you're going to be spending
lots of time with these people
um
and so you know some people like for
example
um
my brother gets a very annoyed at um
repetitive noises okay
um
to a greater scent than than most people
and like it's fine
um and I inadvertently sometimes make
these uh repetitive noises
um which
does not make it like a relationship
with him all that amazing all the time
but yeah we figure out how to deal with
it
um but if you're going to be in a larger
relationship with someone of any uh sort
that has these things that that tend to
get on your nerves more than other
people then you either need to figure
out how to deal with that or to say well
maybe I need to not find this person in
my life as much yeah I was just laughing
because I will make random noises of a
whole variety when I'm kind of thinking
or on my own and uh my youngest kid does
that too and I found it irritating when
she did it and and my wife pointed out
to me well you do exactly the same thing
so I don't know why you find it
irritating I was like well now I
understand why it's here
so so coming back to the the relativity
of it
um I mean we we do have to talk about
like cultural differences you brought up
one of those already in terms of uh
smoking
um but there could be all sorts of
things and we don't necessarily want to
excuse everything on the basis of
culture as well that's just that
person's culture so you have to
understand and put up with it
um but there will be some significant
variances we could say right
yeah there's going to be you know
um
ill obviously like inter
Faith couples can have some very
difficult things not only right you know
their their individual practices but
also their their family's expectations
of them
um which can potentially be a deal
breaker if your friends or family just
despise your partner that's going to be
going to put a lot of strain on that
relationship
um and you have to make a decision
that's something that's worth it or can
you uh live with potentially alienating
a part of your family yeah I mean family
is kind of an interesting thing I was
just thinking about a red flag that I
totally missed when I was in college and
then found out that I should have paid
close attention to I went on a date with
this this girl
and when I was introduced to her mom her
mom said her mom took me aside and said
to me I think you're too good for her
and I was like wow that's a terrible
thing to say about your your daughter
you know and I I reacted the wrong way
but really she was trying to warn me and
this was a person who
um we went on a date she actually
um came to pick me up at College up in
in you know uh Lakeland College past
Sheboygan drove me down here to
Milwaukee we spent some time together
and then we went to see a concert at
shank Hall and something went
topsy-turvy I don't know what it was but
you know at some point in the night
she's like we're leaving and I was like
oh okay that that's a little weird but
uh okay and I had all of my stuff in an
army duffel bag and she drove me to my
mom's place and in Waukesha at the time
and she just like dumped me off there
and she was like I don't ever want to
see you again and I was like where the
hell did this come from right and you
know her mom was trying to warn me that
should have been a red flag you know
somebody's the very first time you meet
their parent their parents saying
something strange about their their kid
and you know I got a ride back up to
school but I was like totally shocked by
what happened you know
yeah so yeah
not only the the
indicators you're getting directly from
the person but also from the people
around them and how they react to them
that's right yeah I mean do you have do
you have any stories about like crazy
red flags that you missed at one point
in time or
no I can't figure adolescence is in the
early 20s are probably full of these
[Music]
sure
and you want to say on the on the radio
though yeah I'm gonna say that yeah okay
well let's talk about other red flag
examples that we uh uh tabulated yeah
so you know what on the internets and
try to you know find there's obviously
some of the big ones like you that get
repeated often like um if you're
um your dates if you go on a date to a
restaurant and your dates uh treats your
your waiter or waitress um
badly yeah then that's that's a good
indication that they don't you know care
about like the smaller people in life
and I was like well do you do you want
to be with a person that has such little
regard for the people that are you know
potentially the serving staff
um how does that respond to you if they
see you as like you know not on their
level or something
um or just you know in general
um but there's there's other ones that
was one of the ones that my students
came up with like immediately oh yeah
yeah what do you think about that I
think that
um you're you're completely right that
there's there's a Badness involved in
treating people who are in a vulnerable
position
and have less social status so it could
be like
um serving staff the bartender it could
also be how they treat people in in
retail stores or how they treat
um secretarial staff or janitorial staff
you know I think those are kind of touch
Stones right and the other thing that I
I think is important to keep in mind if
they're going to treat other people that
way
sooner or later they're going to treat
you that way they're going to come to
see you they're going to look at you as
like there to serve them most likely so
it's a bad sign when somebody
what would you say they're arrogant they
they learn it over others
to you know to to grab a little Emmanuel
const to see people as uh mere means
mere means and not ends into the of
themselves yeah that's that's actually a
great way to to put it
um
when we talk about using people that's
part of what Kant is is after there and
to uh to instrumentalize them to turn
them into things to be used yeah as if
they're like your cell phone and you're
you're telling Siri what to do you know
right
although it's interesting if we want to
continue that yeah on I feel a little
bit weird when
um people are rude to the digital like
Syria oh I shouldn't even see saying
these or uh the Alexa yeah I don't think
that's that I think you're on to
something there you know you know and
again Kant is uh one of the people who
points out that we can learn a lot about
human beings not he's not thinking about
you know robots or AI but he talks about
animals and Kat thinks that there's a
radical difference between us and the
other non-rational animals but
um somebody who treats animals badly
that should be a red flag oh yeah
absolutely it's also especially if
they're like
violent towards Sunday that's actually a
precursor for other really negative
things going down the line but it's
going back to like the technology thing
so
you know like treating uh Siri as if
it's just um
a punching bag
swearing at Siri right that would be a
red flag don't you think yeah a little
bit um like I obviously like
I don't think it's conscious and I don't
think I can actually hurt their feelings
yeah
um but it's a you know a general how do
you
practice to communicate with people
because you're practicing to communicate
people in a really rude or negative way
um you I guess it's one of these
indicators these uh you know gut
feelings of okay well if you're gonna do
that to that which is like the lowest
the loads it's not even conscious yeah
hopefully
um
at this point in time then uh how are
you going to reverse so respond to other
you know people that you might see below
you
I think that makes a lot of sense
um any other particular examples you
want to bring up at this point or
yeah um if the uh the person like never
takes responsibility you know if they
um if anything that happens to him is he
always shifts the blame to someone else
or something else yeah or the situation
that's you know a bigger plague you know
sooner to or and so it's going to turn
you back on you because sooner or later
um stuff's gonna be your fault the the
relationship goes sour and it's it's
nothing that they did it's it's
something that you did yeah and that
would that would actually make it quite
difficult if you wanted you know a lot
of relationships there's going to be
conflict of some sort so how do you
fight fair yeah this is like a red flag
for somebody who won't fight fair
isn't it right absolutely
um and then kind of
um maybe on the the opposite uh end of
this are people that um are constantly
putting uh especially in a romantic
relations that only put your needs first
um yeah because now that's an
interesting one I noticed when you when
you're writing that down now why is that
a bad thing I think some people would be
like oh that's perfect for me you know
um I would I would see that as a red
flag though I'm curious to see why you
would say it is
um because if if they're they're
constantly like totally externally
focused then they're not seeing you as
like especially you're talking about my
romantic Partners not seeing you as a
romantic partner but like a project and
that you're uh not a partner to them
you're a distraction okay
and they may not even realize this but
that's one of those things that uh we
have to deal with yeah uh I mean I think
that is a a very interesting topic that
could be like its own whole discussion
the
um
treating somebody as a project you know
that that's also kind of an
instrumentalizing of them but right you
know like good right you know and it
might be like a total Kobe mechanism
because they're uh you know they might
be like uh selfless and caring and
totally doting on you but they're
actually avoiding their own problems
they're not dealing with their own
things yeah
um just another example of how this
could be potentially negative when on
the surface level it might sound really
great yeah the super supportive partner
quite true so one of the things that
that's a feature of red flags is that
there there's some of them that are
really easy to notice like you know
let's say you're on a dating site and
you're looking at people's profiles and
they're like you know
um must love guns and shooting puppies
or something like oh why well that's it
for that person right uh huge red flags
right there or I love to uh Gamble with
funds that I Rob from the local bank
okay that's that's a big red flag right
at the start as well
um but I think a lot of them are harder
to see and register as red flags until
you're already entangled with the person
you're already involved with them and
then you're posed with some problems I
mean maybe some other people will
criticize you and say well you should
have noticed this before if you had if
you had a problem with this you should
have brought it up at the start you
might even yourself feel that way too
right you could be like oh well I don't
know uh maybe maybe I should uh we we
second guess ourselves maybe I I didn't
notice it before because it's not really
a red flag you know
so that's that's a problem
uh
absolutely this uh
but uh in the new relationships we often
find ourselves oh
um you know putting on a little bit of
facility you dress up you put on your
best clothes you're not going to walk
around being like the
as schwabby as you uh are on you know
whenever you're not caring about what
other people do but you're putting up a
little bit true yes the more the most
polished version of yourself and we're
also doing this not just in romantic
relationships but in the workplace you
know the first week that you're there
you're like on your best behavior you
know the thing about you you go on our
first dates like I went on an interview
you know you put on your nice suit
trying to put your best foot forward and
then only like once one feels
comfortable do some of these things
start to
um eek out of the corners and uh the
question is uh can you remain Vigilant
enough to actually see them
um once you've already become at least
partially enamored with someone
that's that's a good word too
um Vigilant not in the sense of like
constantly being on your guard right but
when when something weird happens to be
able to register it as such and not just
immediately write it off
right and so you know
often we're so close to the situation
it's really hard for us to see them um
and on even if we're trying to be
vigilant that we're uh too close to it
and you know sometimes it's useful to
have a sounding board as someone else
that you you know a friend that
um you'll ask
what they think about someone instead of
because like I it's usually rather go
short you know uh
to
go out of your way to tell your friend
that you think that their partner is bad
unless it's like dangerous bad yeah um
but if you you trust a friend too it's
like hey I think we have a
give me give me some feedback
um that that takes away that taboo
and there is that Dynamic too of uh
people who are
problematic or dangerous in some
particular ways often try to isolate you
from those sounding boards right so that
you you won't get that feedback and then
you'll you'll you know you'll be kind of
second guessing yourself as I said and
not sure of your own reactions
yeah absolutely the whole isolation is
an incredibly large red flag but you
know if if you
one of the same things that happens in
in these types of things is people only
tell you that like you know I'm the only
one that loves you and everyone else is
hates you or is going to uh nobody
appreciates you like I do yeah exactly
um and so it
it's it's a major red flag
um then hopefully you can catch that
because you know they've already got to
the point of isolating you then you're
not going to be able to see it
externally that happens in professional
situations too like with like mentoring
sometimes nobody's going to be able to
coach you like I can you know don't
listen to those other people over there
I know what's best for your career you
know
so there and there there's a power
imbalance it's not like a romantic
relationship where at least
theoretically people are equal right is
this a type of mentoring that's like you
know employees or boss employee or is
this could be are I mean I've seen this
happen in academic settings where you
get a professor who is going to be the
director the mentor for you know a
student and they they steer them the
wrong way you know and other people try
to give them you know some well-meaning
advice about it but then that's a sign
that they're the problem these other
people who are giving the advice and
then they
you know sometimes this screws up
people's careers pretty pretty badly you
know
only everything was just like so you
know cut and dry and everything was well
that's it there's a kind of ambiguity to
to red flags right we we often present
well that this is a definite red flag
this is so clear well it's it's often
not to the people who should be noticing
the red flags a lot of times they can be
you know explained away
um right and so this is a good place to
talk about the possible range of
reactions actually not just possible
these are what people do in relationship
to red flags and and one of them is just
pretend that there isn't any red flag at
all there you just like bury your head
in the sand like the ostrich you make
excuses for the person you find some way
to make it right in your head at least
for the time being
um and you know if that can actually
produce stable situations uh provided
it works out for everybody but it's
probably not going to be a good uh
resolution to a situation right
yeah the
I don't know
there's such a wide variety of responses
here that either you you notice it and
you yeah you can like immediately like
if you're so well versed in this then
you're like okay and you know exactly
what your values and the expectations
and that relationship are that you kind
of like nip that in the bud I mean I
don't think most people fall into that
category and looking back in my own life
I certainly haven't in a lot of cases
and then there's going to be those
people that are going to
um ignore it
um for a while yeah until it becomes too
large or nagging
um to become uh too obvious for them to
do it or people are they're you know
will go through like a 30-year marriage
and ignore them the entire time yeah and
that's that's really tragic because you
you know you consume if you have a
30-year marriage let's say you manage to
live 80 years you've consumed not quite
half but you know well at least half of
your adult life right in in that and so
that's quite an investment there another
set of reactions are what we you know we
often talk about fight or flight but
there's actually three F's there's also
freeze and these are sort of like you
know
um base limbic level reactions that that
people have you see a red flag and you
think oh I better argue with this person
or I'd better get away from this person
or you just uh
freeze in place and let them do what
they're going to do and those aren't
rational responses those are you know
deeply emotional responses that are not
going to do us an awful lot of good and
there's other emotional reactions too I
think you know I mean with the fight you
could talk about anger or indignation
you might also
feel a sense of disgust or contempt
towards the person that is raising the
flags but you could also feel fear of
them you know especially if you've been
traumatized by somebody like that before
or sadness or embarrassment or guilt or
shame on your own part which then that
person might might exploit you know
absolutely one of the topic here is how
do we rationally respond to these things
yeah and and so our
sticking in this kind of like lower
level limbic you know what was this the
sometimes referred to as a reptilian
blade brain yeah yeah your area
um we're not we're not talking about
rational responses this is very you know
based level and so how how does one
build structures to help bring this more
up into our you know primary you know
prefrontal cortex to our rational selves
yeah so that leads to another sort of
response which can be kind of successful
depending on what you're doing with it
it's the inquisitive trying to figure
out why do they do that you know it's
sort of like when you come home from uh
elementary school and you got in a in a
fight on the playground with the bully
and and your parents are not
particularly helpful because they're
like well you must have said something
or why why would they be so mean to you
and you're like they're just a mean
person you know
um and and we do this you know we we're
naturally trying to figure out what
other people's motivations are and what
what drives them
um is it just their ignorant and don't
understand what they're doing do they
have bad character or bad intentions or
is somebody else forcing them to be that
way you know
um now all of these are possible but
none of them provide a reason why you
should ignore the the red flags right
right because
it as we said really early on it could
be an indicator of like very negative
outcomes either like emotionally or
physically yeah and
um so uh Redman it could be indicator of
of potential violence and you need to
break things off really quickly
um and if it's not direct violence but
like emotional manipulation on this you
know uh lead to long-standing issues on
as well as you're you're wasting your
time with someone that is not
trustworthy yeah and it could be too
that the person actually is acting out
of ignorance in which case
um maybe giving them information or
directing them towards something could
could change the situation but then
there's some people who are just bad
actors and you know they actually will
pretend that they're ignorant and and uh
use it that way so you know
communication is uh useful in some cases
like laying down limits or boundaries
saying I won't put up with this this is
a red line you better not cross it
um now you have to be able to stick to
that though I mean if you lay down Line
in the Sand and they keep Crossing it
and you keep like saying well let me
draw another line over here you know
you're telling somebody it's okay to to
keep pushing you around right
yeah this reminds me of
um from like habit making there's this
idea of uh implementation intentions
where you're writing down kind of if
then statements okay and so it might so
to say like on if I wake up in the
morning
um then I'm going to uh go for a three
mile run
um and so you could potentially modify
this into just if then statements about
your relationship and you like say like
every month I'm going to re revisit my
list
um yeah my partner is
is doing X then I need to either
confront them about this why they're
doing this
um or
um I need to see if this is still a
viable relationship
yeah and and maybe you like plan an exit
strategy or something like figure out
where your support network uh
is was could be that's that's actually I
I kind of like that so tell me more
about that I mean I realize this is a
bit of a tangent but how is the placing
it in terms of hypotheticals
um how does that help you out
to a certain extent this is also like
pulling from the stoic practice of
premeditata malorum okay so we're going
to think about what are the negative
things that could happen in a
relationship and how does one properly
rationally respond to these instances
and so as we're talking about just
earlier this whole limbic system this
really base emotional system is going to
potentially result in us making either
rash or poor decisions in the the
um Heat of the Moment and it is much
better for us to already have thought
about some of these
um potential outcomes negative outcomes
okay ahead of time so that
[Music]
um
and then you can you can make a plan
it's like okay if someone does you know
here's if someone if my partner hits me
yeah um that's that's a major red flag
and I I know exactly
um that uh how to like break off any
ties with them make sure that I'm safe
from them yeah you know uh find the
people that are as you said your support
network and go to that
um and so you already got it all set up
so you're not like right so you don't
have to like Figure It Out In the Heat
of the Moment yeah
yeah that's actually a great idea I mean
it could lead to maybe over planning you
know like somebody could have a whole
notebook of if that's right but it's
probably better to have more of those
floating around than less of those right
yeah because if you go into the
relationship and just like this is gonna
be the one everything is going to be
amazing and then
when you know more often than not your
relationships are not going to be kind
of that forever one you know yeah I've
gone through quite a few years
yeah on I didn't marry all of them nor
did you
yeah and it works that way for jobs too
I mean people get get super stoked oh
this is going to be the best job ever
right and then like you know two weeks
into it they find out not quite so much
you know there's all these annoying
factors and and so there's there's two
counter tenancies that we were going to
talk about
um one I think you started on this idea
that it's all gonna work out you know
it's all going to be great even though
there's red flags people will often go
from relationship to relationship and
they're like this time it's gonna be
different you know or I'm gonna do the
same thing and I'm gonna be with
somebody who does pushes the same
buttons raises the same red flags but
this time I'm better prepared I'll I'll
get through it and
that doesn't seem like a great strategy
right
right and this is you know the same idea
of like why
um
what is that the positivity
psycho uh you're not thinking about
positive psychology where you're trying
to have a preposition of good over bad
emotions or positive or over negative
just like
um you know every the the predisposition
that everything's just going to work out
okay which what sets you up for
potential failure because you've never
actually prepared for the the negative
consequence potential consequences yeah
yeah
um and he was like yeah I just have to
be positive
um and then you know like trying to do
it through sheer willpower right right
yeah
or wishful thinking
you know right what's Wishful singing
you know yeah I mean the other tendency
is to fight the last war as they they
say you know you
um
you get burned in a relationship and
you're like never again you know and
then you get into a new relationship and
somebody does some of the same stuff and
you're like they're one of those people
I I have to break it off and maybe maybe
they're doing some similar things but
maybe not with the same motivation uh or
even with the same effects
right so like for example
um we tend to overfit and especially
like if you you come out and like maybe
you got cheated on and now you're you're
hyper Vigilant about anything that you
think is associated with someone being a
cheater in a relationship yeah and
um and now they're like oh well
um
they didn't respond to my texts
immediately therefore they're with
someone and
um and thus they're they're cheating on
me you're going on that whole line of of
thinking right right and you know I
guess
it makes sense because you've been
primed from previous experience but that
does you know there is a a whole bunch
of very innocuous other reasons why they
might have not responded to you yeah
especially back in the day when uh phone
batteries didn't last so long or or even
further back as well too right yeah say
good coverage was bad so like you'd go
into a dead zone yeah but I'm just like
how did we deal with this before we had
like text messaging and cell phones you
just like you know he called me from the
pay phone
that that is indeed what we would do I I
remember uh using pay phones and like
you know calling somebody to work
something out right and you'd be like
out there in the cold with the phone up
to your ear and you'd have to keep
putting money in sometimes yeah so
ridiculous what we used to do
that's what that is
almost purely from like old episodes of
Seinfeld or mad about it okay yeah yeah
where
um like by the time that I was out of
high school on
we had cell phones yeah true
yeah I mean
I don't want to go into one of those you
know I used to walk up the hill both
ways and it was snowy and all that sort
of nonsense but there you know phones
back in the day really did suck uh
compared to what we have now
I mean one phone for the whole house and
you have a very long cord and you like
have to pull it into your bedroom or
something in order to have a little bit
of privacy you know but we could go on
and on about about technology stuff well
let's talk about
um what it takes to develop a mature
perspective about red flags not not a
knee-jerk foolish perspective
what do you think is is important well I
guess you know
you know grab a little Aristotle here
for a moment and do a golden mean that's
neither overreacting or under reacting
that you need to be both aware and
conscious of these things
um but try not to overfit but this is
also one of those things that tends to
uh develop with experience and it's okay
rather hard to go like well I'm just
gonna like make sure to only react to
these things in the appropriate way
yeah I mean there probably aren't
a whole set of rules that we could come
up with that would fit every situation
right so we need something like
practical wisdom or Prudence in order to
sort these things through I mean we use
that word values a while back and I I
kind of like that rather than rules
um yeah because rules are inherently
deontological it's like yeah if x do y
are like you know here's a hard line uh
you know
do this not that and if we are putting
in the decision making into more of a
values or you know virtue on based
um way about it you're thinking about
this in a more rational ways like okay
um how can we look about this and like
how how can I be
um
uh true to myself and and seeing these
uh red flags but also you know still be
like potentially kind to my partner that
is presenting these things and how do I
uh go about trying to advocate for
myself and what I need but while also
not totally alienating the other person
that is actually a really great point
and and I think that ties in with
another you know we've brought up um
virtue ethics and uh deontology and I I
think you could also draw upon ethics of
care where
um empathy compassion for others a
recognition of their vulnerable
vulnerability is important if somebody I
mean there are some really bad actors
out there right but I think a lot of
people who raise red flags it's because
they're dealing with damage trauma you
know being mixed up themselves and you
don't have to like automatically see a
red flag and then like let's destroy
that person you know or I I cast you out
into the darkness where there is Wailing
and gnashing of teeth I mean you could
be like like listen uh I don't like this
thing and this seems sketchy to me if
you're going to continue to act like
this I can't be with you or I can't work
with you or you know we can't be
business partners but
um I do want you to you know do well you
could you could have that sort of
response and I think that's pretty
important that's a great point
yeah
um and so I guess this is you know
developing
um your guts uh on yeah I mean these
things we talked about that at the very
beginning intuition do you think that
intuition
is a good guide in in this sort of thing
as I I often feel about intuition it's
um
a good starting point
um but it should it's not the end-all
be-all that is okay just because you
have a feeling doesn't mean that that
feeling is an accurate representation of
reality
that is a great distinction
um
making it a starting point making it one
out of several things that you're
bringing to Bear rather than just
relying upon it you know and and you can
say that you could like make your
intuition better maybe but I don't I
don't know that you you actually can
um
and so like
my caveat is if you're if you're feeling
an intuition of danger then it's
probably good to um especially if it's
immediate to act on it rather than not
um but if it's not an immediate danger
then sit and like really contemplate
this because you are getting some
signals from
um some part of your brain that says
that there's something wrong
um
but you know sometimes uh the stick on
the path in the forest is a stick and
sometimes it's a snake uh uh yeah you
know this is a bit off topic but I used
to work uh Security on second and third
shift and you know you you get a little
bit sleep deprived when you work those
kinds of shifts and it's dark and you
know you're wandering around and you're
being vigilant because you're you know I
mean if unless you're a bad security
guard you're not being vigilant right
and uh exactly that happens you'll see a
stick and you're I I guess you could
call it a kind of hallucination you'll
hallucinate that stick into being a
snake
or another one that I would see quite
often would be certain kinds of bushes
would look like like a deer just a deer
standing still you know and you know
what and you could tell yourself
rationally that is not a deer I've
walked past this every day for the last
week that is a bush but you're you're
it's not your icing it's your brain
seeing it as such right and our brains
are incredible pattern matching machines
that's true and and they will sometimes
match things that are not actually
imagines yeah it's like hell look look
at any one of your power outlets your
brain goes that looks like little things
exactly yeah
somebody actually uh at Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design they have um
you know those those newer drinking
fountains where there's the thing to
fill the water bottle up and so there's
like a spigot and stuff like that and
they took two googly eyes and pasted
them right on top of that and as soon as
you see the googly eyes you can't not
see this thing as like a little mouth
trunk kind of thing you know yeah
ah so um
well did we uh go ahead I was gonna say
I was like you
um elicited some responses from social
media or any any of those that you
really liked yeah earlier today I I put
it out there in
um Twitter Facebook YouTube LinkedIn and
Mastodon and I got more responses in
Facebook than anywhere else but a lot of
the responses were actually kind of off
base
so we're gonna talk about some of those
in a bit but here here are some of the
better ones so this was actually in
Mastodon and the person later on
clarified that they didn't mean what I
took them to mean so they wrote people
who opened the relationship by naming
some abstract value they espouse now I
took open the relationship to me and
like create it taking like a exclusive
relationship and turning it
non-exclusive like you know saying we're
gonna have an open marriage or something
like that right and then they clarify
that what they meant is begin the
relationship uh but I I responded to
that and I was like yeah actually that
kind of makes sense I mean if if you're
in a committed relationship and your
partner is like yeah we're going to
start seeing other people without like
Consulting you on that and then they
appeal to some sort of you know abstract
value or some I don't know they read
something in a magazine that's a that
should be a red flag and I think that
could also apply to business contexts
right where you say these are the rules
of the game here's what the workplace
looks like and now I'm going to
arbitrarily change the rules maybe bring
in some new vendors or something like
that without consulting you and I'm
going to do it on the basis of
efficiency or pick whatever else you
want
I I do think that's a red flag I mean
what do you think
yeah to
anytime
it's sort of a relationship especially
if they're supposed to be
some like in a romantic relationship
there's back and forth right
um and so one person
doesn't get too you know summarily just
go oh we're going to change the nature
of this relationship that has to be a
agreed upon things yeah unfortunately in
most you know business especially if
you're talking about like a boss versus
employee
um
it's a it's a you know
um dictatorial that's right organization
and so like they get to do whatever they
want I guess and so you and your
response is I might leave which doesn't
seem like a really good response for
actually creating a better workplace it
just means like you know hopefully that
your boss isn't you know a bad person
yeah yeah and uh
but if you're talking about like
business partners then yeah then that
that's going to be
um something that's going to should have
a back and forth there yeah you know I
would say too going from my own
experience when you have like let's say
you're supplying a product to somebody I
I learned that you have to build into a
contract that you get like three
rewrites and then you start paying for
per hour because otherwise you'll get
people who are like yeah
I like what you got here but I want it
completely different can we start from
the ground up and you're like I've
already put like a hundred hours into
this you know uh and you know that's
that kind of it's not opening the
relationship but it's changing the
conditions of what was what was being
expected
right and
that's why they they're a good contract
is incredibly important within business
otherwise people are going to take
advantage of me yeah you know a lot of
people are like oh this should be a red
flag well we don't really need a
contract whoa that's amazing we're good
people we're all you know we can all get
along yeah yeah no
no no no uh any any others that you
particularly liked well I I wanted to
see what you think about this one so
when a non-scientist appeals to Quantum
Mechanics to support a claim with little
to no support otherwise now I don't
think that it has to be necessarily
quantum mechanics I think it could be
any buzzword so it could be you know
Neuroscience it could be pick whatever
you like whatever the flavor of the day
is I think there's a lot of people who
use and they may not even appeal to
Quantum Mechanics they'll just use the
word Quantum we got a quantum computer
here and you're like what's exactly
Quantum about it you know how is this
connected to it I think there's a lot of
this this uh stuff out there among you
know new agers and people who are kind
of woo but I think this permeates the
business world too and I I see it all
the time in educational institutions you
know there are so many like snake oil
salesmen in the business world I was
like oh I've got the new big thing you
know
and I guess I haven't really looked into
like Six Sigma but like that's
definitely one of these like buzzwordy
type things yeah like this whole like
marketing approach to it and they sell
all these you know classes and whatnot
um well that might actually be a good a
good I mean I'm not going to say that
every
group that sells a curriculum is raising
a red flag but the fact that there's
like a big slick curriculum out there
ought to make us at least a little
suspicious
right right
and going back to this like specifically
Deepak Chopra is constantly talking
that's true yeah
they're just like and like waves it's
like it's the quantum or or whatever
yeah on
and she I've seen him like be like
confronted by it like a Quantum
physicist just like what are you talking
about like none of those things that
you're saying make any sense but it's
like this as I said it's a buzzword to
like kind of like wipe off but I wonder
is this like red flags in relation to
relationships or into like if you want
to believe someone that's making a point
well I mean if somebody in your
relationship is constantly talking about
Quantum this and that that's probably a
bad sign you know
but I think I think that's more like a
red flag about like things in the
general culture people trying to sell
you a program that you should get
involved in right I guess
it definitely comes to the idea of how
does people come to on their conclusions
if they're okay yeah allows them to
um believe someone that says like you
know uh these uh
essential oils are going to cure your
cancer yeah
um then I'm going to ask I'm going to be
suspect of how they actually came to
believe those things in the first place
it's interesting because it's it's not
quite an appeal to Authority the fallacy
that we would maybe place this under but
it's more like an appeal to a well-known
but not well understood product
methodology
buzzword something like that yeah like
sometimes it will be a pill to Authority
if you're like oh well like you know
you know doctor what's his name who got
his
um you know the Buenos Iris uh
University for
um herbology and his uh rocks and
whatnot yeah on
uh I was like yeah sure like he sounds
cool and he but he might just be a snake
of a Salesman and
um just because there's a whole bunch of
people that talk about this like you
know this is
by a particular issue with like
astrology astrology has been around for
you know thousands of years now well
this is a good one because that we're
gonna we're gonna run out of time pretty
quickly and and uh but so I think we can
only do one more so one that they talked
about people who appeal to personality
traits to excuse behavior and do the
same with others also they said
appealing to horoscopes right so saying
well this this person or I am this way
like people do this with the
Myers-Briggs I I'm this kind of person
therefore I have to behave this way to
me that should be I think that that is a
legitimate red flag what do you think I
I absolutely agree like I I want to be
you know judged by my own actions and
um
and those things aren't uh essentialist
uh that you know just because uh either
of you know Myers-Briggs or whatever you
know horoscope you might be says these
things it should absolutely not excuse
um you know if you were an angry person
and are I guess what they call like a
fire sign or whatever and you're yeah
what not no that that's something you
should be working on with your like
therapist or something because uh just
because uh you know someone else says
something doesn't give you an out
well that is pretty much all the time we
have so do you want to lead us out on
Yeah final thought uh yeah so we leave
you the words of
um here setting you know that's funny
when you look at someone through
rose-colored glasses all the red flags
just look like legs
[Music]